hello everyone and welcome to the remake
of a video I made like a year ago now as
I've already mentioned in game number
two of this match 1971 candidates match
between Bobby Fischer and Mark taimanov
I already made a video on Game three it
was about one year ago but all things
have changed you know I have a lot more
vast knowledge not to use in my videos
and in that while I was making that
video a year ago I thought I didn't
think I'd make all of the videos so I
thought I'd only make one game from the
match and then I pretty much stuffed
everything about the match and you know
the game in that one video so as a lot
of you have requested an additional
video on this game I started to make a
remake it will not be in you know 4k or
8k or something it will still be in 1
ATP but you know the human eye can't
perceive 4k anyway so you know that's
just that would that would just be
stealing your money so like we've said
1971 can this match marked a man of
against Bobby Fischer tomorrow again has
the white pieces and as we've mentioned
in game number 2 the game number 2 is
still being played so well game number
three is started game 2 still didn't
finish because a game number 2 was
adjourned twice so this game will finish
before they continue their adjourned
Game two and this will have a lot to do
with the match but we're going to talk
about that some more during this game as
we don't have a lot of photos we do have
one photo we already showed it during
Game one but there it is just you know
to set the mood
now all that being said let's check out
the game in game number three taimanov
opens with the same line he opened in
Game one so d4 Knight to f6 c4g 693
Bishop to g7 Fischer goes for the Kings
Indian defense
efore d6 Knight to f3 so all the same we
have castles Bishop to e2 ePHI we have
castles knights the CC as c6 and the d5
againt amount of goes for the exact same
variation 97 by Fisher Bishop to d2 we
have 98 rook the c1 and f5 so this is
the exact same position as they already
played in game 1
and if you remember Game one if you
don't I will put a link to it in the
description below you should definitely
check it out before watching Game three
here at amount of in Game one played
captures on f5 at official chapter ski
when tonight for Knight to g5 and you
remember the plan night will come to e6
here official Bulba force to capture it
and then Fisher will win this a six
point eventually but by then tomorrow
will already create a very nice King
side attack and it's this is definitely
the correct way to go for tomorrow mean
this match he doesn't want to go into
long end games with Fisher he just wants
to create some nice beautiful positions
and then start attacking Fisher so after
a 5 hit here he decided to improve this
variation a bit
first he played the Queen to b3 a nice
idea as it lines up the Queen with the
King that is an g8 also it prevents this
light-square bishop from being developed
and tomorrow is ready to push c5 here at
at one point so Fisher plays b6 perhaps
he will develop the Bishop to b7 also b6
is preventing c5 but this does weaken
the light squares on the Queen side as
Tull mentions so here we have e captures
on f5g captors on f5 and yet again nice
the g5 so just an in-between move this
Queen B 3 and B 6 but everything else
will now be the same as in Game one but
very different as you'll see here
there's a choice for Fischer does he
want to go h6 and go into this fourth
line of 96 pawn captures sorry Bishop
captures pawn captures in the now Queen
to c8 the guarding this pawn and be
ready to face c5 whatever the Queen will
already be guarding but it doesn't
matter as the amount of will still be
able to push c5 here after we captures
night here and now White has a very nice
position definitely has compensation for
the pawn of course Queen captures will
be impossible now this is indirectly
defending at Knight captures here and
black will lose the Queen you cannot
capture the Queen is pinned after King
defense in better c4 and black is lost
so okay after 9 g5 Fischer doesn't go
for this force line
it's not forced all the way to losing
your queen but up until 95 so instead he
goes night to a sorry Knight to f6 and
here f4 again
a very nice move Fischer has to decide
whether he wants to go
efore where something like Bishop e3 d4
will be possible and it will be somewhat
hard for a Fischer to develop his pieces
especially the LightSquared bishop so
instead of closing the center official
decides to go for this very nice idea
that is h6 but only now a very forcing
line we have F captures on e5 d captures
on e5 and now c5 here tomorrow creates a
very nice position where d6 is
definitely a threat in all of the
variations for example if you play
something like like H captures and g5
grabbed a knight on d5 d6 is coming with
check King h8 the captures on e7 Queen
captures and the now C capture some b6 a
captures and now Bishop captures on g5
and the white will have a beautiful
position ok perhaps the engine may be
would would say that this is about equal
but with with Fisher's naked King in the
corner White's position will be much
easier to play here
so after c5 another idea is king q h8
simply getting the King out of the pin
but still d6 is a very nice threat and
again what do you do here you can either
capture and then we have pretty much the
same deal or capture here and then D
captures on e7 and again we pretty much
pretty much the same thing so after
Queen captures of course but but maybe
capturing on here is is better than
going to engage at first but ok Fischer
doesn't go for any of this instead he
goes night after night F characters on
d5 of course this is not free by any
means Knight captures on d5 is played by
a man of Knight captures on d5 and here
comes C captures and b6 a very nice idea
as of course Fischer's threat is a
tomorrow's threat is Bishop to c4
pinning this night and there's no good
way to actually prevent this you can
push c6 then the Rockies
you can't block with the butcher because
the night is got a gardening d6 square
if you play but should be 7 the night
does come to e6 attacks your rook and
Queen so a very unpleasant position for
Fischer here at Fischer played a capture
some b6 and here now it's time on of
move you know yeah he really has to make
a choice here does he want to go for the
forcing line rook captures on c7 the
knight cannot capture as it's pinned you
can see this very nice diagonal if the
Queen captures then it's then it's game
over first Queen captures on d5 with
check and then Queen Queen picks up the
rook on a8 so after H capture some g5
you would get better captures on g5 and
again and the Queen cannot capture on g5
because of the same variation or on c7
for that matter but here Fischer would
have Queen to d6 and here it seems that
he's defending properly now Bishop to c4
isn't much of a threat Bishop to e6 will
simply defend and now this this rook and
see a broken c7 does look a bit fishy
here so came after a capture some b6 the
manav goes for a more direct approach he
plays rook the c6 keeps everything on
the board but you know really limits the
Fischer's options so what do you do here
there are a couple of options here for
example if you capture on g5 now then
you're not gonna have too much fun now
push up to c4 will win the game on the
spot there's no way to prevent any of
this
now the rook is guarding d6 square for
example you can move the King King h8
but then you get Bishop captures here
and after you have to prevent Queen to
h3
then this was a result in checkmate
after Bishop blocks and Queen captures
you have to play f4 so the bishop would
be guarding the h3 square but now Bishop
to b4 and whites attack will be will be
unstoppable so yeah after this rook to
c6 also if you play something like
Bishop to f6 maybe not in grab it
immediately but try to prepare grabbing
then the same idea but the c4 will win
you the game so here after some
consideration comes a move that really
really irritated time on of
it's it's a move that is of course a
favorite move by the engine so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
a nice defensive move for black you know
just put yourself in Fisher's shoes here
you were really being attacked here try
try and defend this position
I'll give it a couple of seconds fruit
to the side for those who were able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent defender you know with engine
precision and for those who just want to
enjoy the show here Fischer played King
to a trade and here we have the famous
position that will be discussed for
probably the next century well now not
anymore now that we have engines but in
those days for a very long time here as
I've mentioned in the previous video I
made here ago here at a man off went
into a deep deep think Tom mentions in
his article for for over an hour but I
believe it's closer to 72 minutes so
that's a lot of a lot of thinking for
one move and the estill mentions often
when you go like into a really really
deep thing you will not find a better
move than the one you already thought of
like it's very rare that you will
calculate for for an hour and then find
the move you haven't found like in the
first half an hour or the first 15
minutes I've never heard of such a case
I've you know I've thought about
positions for 40 minutes 50 minutes in
classical tournaments but never really I
never really got it never really got me
anything
so yeah this is the famous position and
here after 72 minutes have passed that
amount of retreated within the night
Knight to f3 as he couldn't find
anything better but here we have a
couple of a couple of ideas that are
indeed very nice Queen to h3 is one such
move that simply prevents Fischer from
capturing the knight and g5 but also
threatens rook captures an h6 of course
this will result in checkmate and this
Queen to h3 move is a move that will
haunt mark tomorrow for the rest of his
life because at least I mean even with
perfect play which
it's hard to imagine oh it's not hard to
imagine Fisher is capable of such play
but it will be it would be extremely
hard to defend this position such moves
would be something like 90 to f6 to
prevent the rook from capturing here but
even here white would have an excellent
game after Bishop to c3 the bishop was
attacked so you have to move it now
Bishop to b7 and here rook to e6 Knight
to g4 offering the Knights to grab the
knight on d5 how about okay but sure
captures Queen captures here comes the
Bishop captures on f5 and white would
have a very strong attack here another
idea after this Queen to h2 remove is
rook to f6
rook to f6 seems to be a bit better but
here comes Bishop to c4 and now you see
the problem
you cannot capture different the rook
and c6 because 9th to f7 will capture
the Queen as it as it comes with a fork
and there aren't all that many moves you
can play here you still cannot capture
so what can you do here f4 of course it
is an idea opening up a discovered
attack from the bishop to the Queen
Queen to f3 comes and then out comes H
captures and g5 rook captures Bishop
captures and now Bishop captures and d5
attacking the rook on a a Bishop to g4
you want this in between move for
example if white captures then black can
capture the bishop here but white would
simply move and now you have to move the
rook and here comes a bishop to c3 and
Fischer would be up upon here but with
with his bare naked King and the bishop
pair slicing in this direction Queen can
come to g6 it would be so much easier to
play this with white and of course it's
always easier to attack them to defend
so this is the critical moment after
this King to h8 move by Fischer a really
stubborn resilient move which time on
have really hated he mentioned this that
he felt like he was doing everything
right he was playing creative beautiful
chess but Fisher seemed like he was
invulnerable so after this h6 moved
amount of simply retreated nice to have
three and now Fischer took this
opportunity to to develop pieces and
grab the initiative Bishop the b7 now
the rook has to move we have looked
six and now Knight to f4 forcing a trade
here as the rook and the bishop on e2
are unguarded you have to capture the
Knight Bishop captures on f4 was played
he captures on f4 and now comes rope to
d1 Queen to e7 we're up to e6 Queen
comes the c5 with check King to f1 King
to h1 is also possible but there are too
many back ranked weaknesses and the king
will be safer on f1 rook a to the 8th
Fischer wants to exchange one pair of
rooks so that one of back ranked
weaknesses will really be felt
we have rook captures on d8 rook
captures and e8 and now Queen to a4 here
preparing rook to e8 we have Queen to c1
check King to f2 and now comes a
beautiful move by Fischer Bishop to f8
preparing the home this bishop in on the
c5 Square and deliver this check this
would be deadly so ty Manifesta
prevented before is played and now comes
the shock to e4 again a beautiful move
blocking this rooks defense of the e3
square and here Queen to e3 will be a
very nice very very nice trap also there
are some hidden traps here but to
understand them we have to see what our
whites options here for example if Queen
to b3 is placed to prevent any Queen e3
ideas then you have this b5 move here
Fischer will simply say okay I'm up upon
you your attack is has been prevented
I mean I'm just winning here I guess of
course you cannot capture it if you
capture then Rudy one will be deadly and
whatever you do here it's very
interesting for example Bishop to e2
there is a beautiful variation here that
wins the game instantly for black it's a
checkmate in 4 so as an exercise as a
puzzle feel feel free to check it out
just to see how reach the rich the
position was so I will give it a couple
of seconds as usual for those of you who
found Queen to c5 check you are
extremely cool and this is the way to go
Bishop to c5 check also works but you
know Queen to c5 is way cooler so you
should play that B captures on c5 Bishop
captures and see if I would check and
now it's all over the King has nowhere
to go as you can see here you
have to block with the Queen and then
Bishop captures III is checkmate or
first you can give up a night but then
after Bishop captures the f3 Square is
still covered by the light square Bishop
still Queen has to block and still
Bishop captures on III will be checkmate
so that's the thing with Queen to b3 so
how about Queen to b5 preventing this
pawn from reaching b5 and you know still
keeping an eye on everything well here's
the problem of Queen III check now
you're not guarding III after King moves
Queen to c1 check King moves and now
comes this Bishop to d5 move simple but
it works you have to move the rookie 5
square is the only is wherever the rook
will not be attacked
now comes the bishop captures on a2 and
now Fischer simply grabbed another pawn
and the whites attack is nowhere to be
found
hey froakie 8 then rock characters Queen
captures and simply Queen III check
forcing a trade of Queens captures
captures captures and now Bishop
captures and on before with 2 extra
points and the bishop pair this would be
easily winning for Fischer
so after this Bishop to e4 move by
Fischer Queen b3 doesn't work win b5
doesn't work a lot of things don't work
so the amount of decided to go for a
nice Queen sacrifice he played rook to
e8 and it seems like a really really
weird move how why do you allow Bishop
the c6 with an attack on your queen and
on the rook but this is all part of
Temenos plan as hidden like Queen b3 or
queen b5 moves so he decided to
sacrifice his queen here Queen captures
on c6 was played we have Queen captures
on c6 and deny Luke captures on d8 so
grabbing some material for the Queen but
you will not be able to capture the
bishop Queen to f6 is played attacking
the rook rook c8 and now Queen to e7 we
have King f1 king h7 and now Knights to
d4 Bishop to g7 and now Knight to the b5
Knight captures on f5 is also very
interesting but it doesn't work now you
have Queen to d7 attacking both the rook
and the night it would be very
unfortunate if you played Queen to e6
here with the same idea because now you
will lose the game due to Bishop to d3
and now the King has nowhere to go
are you are threatening all sorts of
nice discoveries and even if you capture
the rook you
still gonna lose the Queen due to this
check King moves now you're over peace
and winning the game so this wouldn't be
very unfortunate for Fischer but you
know of course he will not allow this
and the time out of soda it doesn't work
so he didn't captured an ID b5 we have
Bishop to e5 and now a3 Queen d7 this is
completely lost for white but you know
you have to try rook to e8 we have f3
now simply making room for the dark
square Bishop G captures and a bunch of
captures on h2 King attacks Bishop and
now Fischer finishes the game with great
style Queen to g7 check of course if you
move the King for example King f2 Queen
g1 will be checkmate so you have to
capture it but then you allow Queen e5
check and it was in this position and
move for the one that the game was
adjourned
but it was never continued of course
because after the King moves you can
capture the bishop and then it's all
over
I'm Knight and rook are no match for the
Queen so yeah that's pretty much it and
it's a very interesting I had to get
back here in this this is definitely the
critical moment perhaps one of the most
critical moments ever missing this Queen
to H to remove tal says that it's this
move that costs diamond of at least a
point and a half because here it cost
him a full point because if he played it
sure tal is sure that he would win this
game against Fischer and then of course
as you already heard in my video on game
number two of this match tomorrow was
probably so frustrated but also he
didn't have that much time to prepare
for for continuing a game to because he
had to prepare for game 3 and also tall
doesn't blame at amount of seconds for
not you know preparing you know some
very nice draw lines for for continuing
game number 2 so that's all very
interesting but now as you all know as
you already seen my video on game to
Fischer is now three points in the lead
and now it's I mean it's a it's a 10/10
game match so anything can happen here
but being down two points and official
did win already two games with the black
pieces so as a bonus for this video
aside for
quint wish to remove I will also show a
very nice engine line that I just you
know found by accident and I thought it
was really beautiful so I decided to
share that with you guys as well
besides the screen 2h to remove there is
also the very interesting bishop to have
to remove and now after blocking the
Bishop Bishop captures we have pawn
captures and now Knight to f7 check rook
captures rook captures and now III
blocking the bishop on d2 now comes Bush
up to e1 and after Queen to g5 here
comes Queen to c2 the threat is rook to
g6 but black doesn't care rook captures
on a2 we have root 2 G 6 and the now
comes rook to a one temporary Queen
sacrifice and g5 rook captures now comes
rook captures anyone with Czech you have
to block with the rook rook to f1 now
comes rock captures King captures and
now Bishop to a6 check King do you want
and now H captures on g5 and now you
have two bishops
and the night with a protected past born
on e3 you know it's a an excellent
position for black but I mean you're
probably not gonna lose with white
because of how open the black king is
but you know only black can win this
position so also one of the moves that
didn't quite work for white but I
thought it was a very nice you know
other nice variation so I decided to
share it as well so yeah but I will not
show the finishing position rather this
one and this Queen to H to remove that I
will use as a thumbnail as it is you
know such a shame that it didn't happen
in Game one in Game three with the white
pieces taimanov played a beautiful chess
and it just wasn't his it wasn't his
match Fischer played I mean
stubborn moves King h8 engines favorite
there's no other than Queen to h3 there
is no good move to counter it but you
know only one only one person can win
the match and in this case so far what
we want all three games so enough of my
rambling I do hope you enjoyed the game
and that you're enjoying the series so
far I
like to thank Jeremy comatose Martin
Johnston don't do an auction options
Donald Anderson and Budi widow for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon with either game number four or
couple of games from the st. Louis rapid
event and also a quick announcement my
my video on receive nojima Dino versus
electronic of the greatest Queen
sacrifice in chess history just past 2
million views today so if you haven't
seen it you know I will also put a link
to that in the description below if you
want to check it out so yeah very happy
that the first video I made that you
know passed two million views is a game
by not none other than Rasheeda Nesmith
Dino's so thank you all and I'll see you
soon